hey Luke here at the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel and today we're doing
the ultimate nerf
[Music]
guys eboard
this nerf war isn't very fun is it you
just want to buy more guns wait your
birthday's coming up right you want to
go and buy a ton of guns and fight all
your friends and have the vagus nerve
forever
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you guys ready to unbox some guns
we have 3600 bullets in these little
packages and I've got to take them out
all right guys we're making progress
keep going Becca what is that
that's the elite Jacob are you helping
look at this mess it's like a hurricane
came in here I'm videotaping you guys
[Music]
well that is a big box of Nerf darts
walk out my trailer loaded up with 400
pounds of Legos left over from my lego
fishing cabin video I've got guns and
ammo in the back of the car tell your
kids to clean up the toys or else
alright here we go
just take handfuls of ammo and dump them
around each one of the little forts and
obstacles there we go attempt somebody
out in the open you guys get shot
anywhere you come back behind this and
then you can start playing immediately
again okay
[Applause]
[Music]
go shoot a child yeah a lot
[Music]
did somebody take your gun let's go get
a bigger gun towards me
[Music]
you wanted this one
[Music]
yes
[Music]
all right everybody times up drop put
your guns down on the ground
guys you guys want rice a little
different everybody versus the bear who
wants to shoot me
and today we're doing the ultimate
[Applause]
[Music]
half of them will be under my couch in a
week well this worked out pretty good I
think we had a good time we guys we had
a great time had loads of fun if you
want to see more great videos from the
outdoor boys YouTube channel don't
forget to we put out new videos every
Saturday morning thanks for watching if
you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watch
[Music]